hi guys so i'm in a cab right now on my
way to the convention center we're here
at ces in las vegas beautiful
las vegas everybody say hi everybody say
hi yay
everybody's so excited i'm excited
oh i'm always excited
all right so i'm here at ces i just got
my badge uh apparently i am an engineer
i'm not sure why since i'm registered as
an engineer but whatever all right so
welcome to ces 2010. this place is
absolutely insane i mean just just look
around just look around you see all the
stuff behind you yeah it's amazing there
are things everywhere
so i keep getting yelled at and i just
realized because i have an engineer
badge holder and apparently people think
that i'm going to steal their technology
but i swear i swear i'm not this is a 3d
led tv
full hd full hd
what do you see right now um i see
monsters jumping out at me 3d it is 3d
like i'm like oh i want to touch a scale
good good good awesome actually it's
really really crispy
it's a little darker in here
all right here at the cnet booth leave
me alone
ryan's over there okay here we go
multiple choice everybody by what
company in the 70s and the 80s look
carefully gentlemen
the commodore that's a
b
is atari
or c
tandy
that is a sound egg
this is cool what does it sound like
it's really good i can barely hear you
guys
i don't really know if i can see myself
having this in my apartment though why
not
so this is an oxygen bar i'm a little
nervous i've never done it before
all right i'm ready like i have a
mustache
it's weird man
it's like i'm chewing gum
like a cherry bubble gum but you don't
even have to chew lindsey how is it
it's awesome
it's run off
for the car 12 volt oh so i couldn't
just buy one right now and like wear it
on myself we could wear than yourself
you could put on your car
this is vegas i'm sure we can find a
12-volt battery somewhere i like it that
looks good
for a little ride
we are in ces and we're checking out a
whole bunch of cool technology things
there is an iphone
wow
here's the griffin band these guys
where did you drive from you drove from
started in nashville which is where
griffin's located and we went all the
way down through new orleans
austin texas phoenix up to vegas she was
the only girl home
hi so i'm here at the into tomorrow
booth i have to whisper because they're
doing an interview right there
but i just want to introduce you to
someone yes my name is rob almanza i
work with into tomorrow i co-host the
show but i'm also a producer and
yesterday we had a company called taser
international
and i got tasered before the show we're
gonna have our video up at our website
uh you can check it out at gravefly.com
and ijustine is gonna be there too we're
interviewing her today so and i'm like
virtually chasing you right now yeah
this one into his
i am outside right now here in front of
a very large
best buy
bus
i think there's a lot of styles
inside the intel booth right now it is
it's huge huge
do you ever forget what you're doing
here i'll let you guys see too so this
is all running on the graphics and the
processor for the new core
family really cool stuff thanks to
cyberlink and the core i5 what's up
sitting here at the intel upload lounge
um i don't really have anything to
upload because all of my footage is on
my camera
um but it feels nice to sit down someday
they'll put wi-fi in the camera and
they're just like uploaded immediately
so this is a really cool little karaoke
thing um he didn't give me a price but
he said it's like you know around 100 or
so but it's really cool because it looks
like a little boom box
so it's just got little audio inputs for
two microphones
this will go out to your tv and yeah i'm
quite impressed
all right so we are here at the
interactive toy concepts and these are
called skeets and they are flying
so let it go
there you go
tell me when you want it
live booth and leo is doing his thing
setup is absolutely crazy i mean
honestly do you need one camera do you
need two cameras to need three oh no no
you need four and seven microphones and
backups of everything it's so
i love it i love it
so we are here at the cta digital and uh
as you guys know i'm a huge wii fan and
they have a ton of wheat accessories
like oh look at this
i am standing right in front of some
iphone cases that are seriously
so bright and so blinging that you would
only find something like this in las
vegas
look at that skull
feels like real death hey guys welcome
to ces i want to introduce you to the
united states postal service they are
here
i mean why wouldn't they be here we go
here we go here we go this is an awesome
touchscreen thing
any given time
you can touch
a cube
and get to the first layer of
information
all of this is being rendered live in
real time you're looking at over 500
links
pulling content from over 10 000
different content sources
including google news
flickr
oh that even works
amazing
blogs and links about what's happening
here at ces
this lady's having a great time look at
her
i love the enthusiasm
it's infectious
all right so they just changed the
visualization to be all tweets
so right now we're looking at only
twitter feeds but we can change this so
you're only looking at google news for
instance or flickr images
we've got really six key platforms
i have to
build a pc faster than anyone else and
i'll win some money for charity i'm
pretty excited